good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from welcome to simply learn we are
honored to have you join us today for
holiday digital marketing review and
wrap up and with your host Matt Bailey
my name is Richard and after this intro
I'll be mostly in the background helping
Matt so that everything goes smooth and
then they'll come back in for the last
15 minutes to help with question and
answers if you do not know Matt Bailey
matt has over 20 years digital market
experience as a trainer working with
Microsoft Google HP IBM and we're here
we are lucky to have him here and simply
learn he's published internet marketing
an hour a day and wired to be Wow and he
has a third book coming out teach new
dogs old tricks I'll let him do a full
introduction shortly at the end we will
do the 15-minute question-and-answer
time and in that 15 minutes I'll collect
it and cover as many questions as we can
if you hear something awesome brilliant
interesting insightful and you want to
share it in your social channels
whatever your social and panels are
Facebook Linkedin tweet you can use the
hashtag SL webinars that way people can
find it and you'll make them wish they
were here you didn't come here to listen
to me I'm proud to introduce Matt will
be your host for a holiday digital
marketing review and wrap up go ahead
and sit back relax have a cup of coffee
tea or if it's evening where you're at
maybe a glass of wine and enjoy it's an
honor for me to have this over to Matt
thank you and happy learning hello Matt
welcome to simply learn today hey thank
you very much I appreciate it excellent
all right go ahead and I looked a
picture of you with the hat that's great
holiday party kappa all right let me go
ahead music i'll turn it off yes we had
to put the holiday hat on and i'm going
to in advance apologize for my voice
just took a very long very fast trip and
i did a lot of talking and lecturing
while I was traveling so my voice is a
bit raw from that and so we're going to
do the best we can and get into this
webinar here now I'm going to talk about
the holiday trends for the past holiday
season now most of this is around the US
Canada and the UK and even some of
Europe is where most of the data is
developed but I have gotten some data
specifically to other regions around the
world so that we can look at how this
time of the year or about how holiday
shopping around the world is being
affected by some of the digital trends
that we see now some of the big trends
that we saw especially this holiday
season is that mobile shopping is up
desktop shopping is up now that's
interesting because over the past few
years we have seen desktop going down
but yet this year desktop shopping went
up dramatically and I'll show your chart
to comparing that and then also email
email is really locking in a place
itself because of the multifunction that
email gives you in that it can be opened
on both mobile desktop however it has
lodged itself and made a great place for
itself in the holiday marking trends now
just a rundown over what's happened on
Friday week thanksgiving day in the u.s.
nearly topped two billion dollars which
is an eleven percent increase from last
year Black Friday came up to 3.3 4
billion which is over twenty one percent
from last year cyber monday was the
biggest day of all the three of Black
Friday week cyber monday was almost at
3.4 billion which is an increase of ten
percent from last year overall mobile
made up 1.2 billion dollars of the
entire sales on those three days which
is up thirty three percent so overall
things are moving positively people are
spending more but
also we're seeing all the numbers
increase through mobile and then also
the overall spending now also this went
over into the UK of the black friday
through cyber monday and the UK even saw
an increase of forty percent compared to
last year they estimated sales almost at
three billion pounds now when people in
the UK were asked why did they do the
shopping on the that weekend sixty-five
percent said it was all because of the
discounts it was because of the deals
that they saw and the retailer's
competing for their business that it was
just a great time to purchase their
gifts or even what they needed for
themselves because of the disk scouts
now of the 61 days that are considered
to be the primary shopping days this is
what was most amazing is that there was
over a billion dollars in revenue
produced 57 out of the 61 days that is a
significant amount of money and numbers
that really is just staggering to think
about the amount of money and how much
is being spent through that time frame
now here's where we talk about the
desktop is that even though desktop had
been going down over the past few years
during this holiday season purchases
from the desktop went over 1 billion for
19 straight days and spending between
november first and december 12 went up
twelve percent to almost 50 billion now
it's interesting year because analytics
firms i've been trying to piece together
how people are shopping they notice
trends of people shopping on their
phones while they were in the store so
they would do comparison shopping on
their mobile phones while they're in the
store and they would do research
shopping now that would sometimes happen
on the mobile but it was also happen on
desktop but people then would tend to
complete the transaction when they had
done research on the desktop device the
main reason for that is because people
feel more comfortable with concluding
the transaction on a desktop because the
screen is larger and because they can
see all of the details that are on the
page sometimes on the mobile device
people aren't sure that they're seeing
all of the necessary information and so
the trust factor isn't quite there they
want to be sure that they see everything
it's in the field of view and they
aren't missing anything so in that case
we're seeing that the desktop is sort of
the default methodology or the default
method that people are using in order to
apply it finance their purchase now this
chart shows us over the past few years
the breakdown and this is US Canada and
even into the UK of the breakdown
between smartphone tablet and desktop
and you can see smartphone sales
smartphone traffic increasing over the
past three years but yet smartphone
sales really kind of stayed the same
ultimately over the entire holiday
season smart phone traffic went down
just a tick tablet sales were about the
same but as you can see when we get to
the desktop sales had been going down
over the desktop and went back up about
4% really kind of taking from the
smartphone and traffic backup from the
desktop as well so we're seeing that
really kind of even out what happens
next year I think desktop is still going
to hold and it may not lose that could
be percent market share
of traffic and it may hold it around
that sixty to sixty-five percent market
share when it comes to sales now again
when I talked about when people are more
comfortable checking out on a desktop
because they can see everything in the
field and they can know that they're
seeing all the numbers making sure that
all of the available data is within
their field of view that is borne out
when we look at the conversion rates by
individual device so we can see that the
desktop conversion rate is about
five-and-a-half percent and that drops
from their tablets is almost five and
then smartphones was about a half of
that tablets are still more closely
related to the desktop because there's
more screen area people can see all the
information that's their smartphone
conversion rate it's still pretty low
and until the interface matches with the
smartphone and people feel more
comfortable checking out on a smartphone
I think we're still going to see the
conversion rates lower for the device
more than half of what it is for desktop
until designers website owners take
steps to ensure that the checkout
process is seamless and easy as well as
making people comfortable that they're
seeing all the information that they
need to see in order to complete the
transaction now when we look at specific
channels the number one source of
traffic was organic and paid search the
second source was direct traffic that's
people typing in the website directly
and then the last one was email fifteen
percent those are the top four sources
of traffic to websites over the holiday
season now it comes down to sales search
both paid and organic search accounted
for forty percent of the sales direct
traffic again people typing in the
website directly
it's about twenty percent but then what
was surprising is that email made up of
over seventeen percent of sales that
means that retailers who have lists of
customers were sending out emails
regularly with sales announcements
throughout the holiday season and
ultimately email became one of the top
channels for generating sales now
conversely one of the last channels that
was effective we can see here is social
media came in at just under one percent
in generating sales now search direct
and email and generating sales all three
of those channels were up over prior
year's display and social are down from
past years and so very interesting to
see how the primary channels of search
paid and organic and email are
contributing to overall revenue whereas
other channels such as display and
social we're not nearly as effective in
driving sales so the best performing
channel organic search if you're looking
to see what people are going to be
investing in over the next year it's
organic search the top priority of most
marketing executives as you can see here
over eighty percent of marketing ected
executives are going to increase in
digital advertising content marketing
and search engine optimization because
that is the number one way that they
were generating sales and new customers
over the holiday season the other thing
I talked about was email now I said you
know it was seventeen point eight
percent were generated by email on Cyber
Monday it went up to twenty percent
alone and that really could make it
makes sense one out of every five sales
were attributed to email that's up
thirty-three percent from last year and
that is a significant number what that
means is retailers are investing more in
personalization in developing email
messages that are specific to their
audience that are recommending based on
previous purchases and based on the
customer history when asked what the
most influential media was throughout
that Black Friday Cyber Monday timeframe
fifty-six percent of people put into
email as the most influential media that
prompted them to purchase now what's
interesting as we see all of our social
media filling out the rest of the chart
and it did move some revenue it did move
sales but email is different in that it
can be personalized it can it's one to
one from the company to the consumer and
the more companies personalize those
emails the more they direct them towards
the interests based on the past history
the more effective they are in
generating those sales also email is not
only a cross-channel it's across device
it's amazing because email is a unifier
we can see here that the opens on a
mobile or generating fifty percent of
revenue compared to desktops only two
years ago email was only generating
about thirty percent of revenue and so
in two years it's climbed twenty percent
to make up a significant gap so we know
that we send an email people are going
to see it regardless of whether it's
desktop or mobile and we can also
customize it based on that we can make
sure that our emails I have to be mobile
friendly because we don't know when
they're going to open it or how they are
sometimes we can
look for it that during the day it may
be different depending upon the night
just depending upon your audience or who
they might be you want to make sure that
your emails are going to be opened
regardless of device and also
personalize now one of the things that
has been losing out in the holiday
season was the buy buttons in the social
network so if a retailer wanted they
could put their products on a social
network like a Pinterest or Instagram or
Twitter and you could buy from their
update now unfortunately there's not
been a lot of interest in that in fact
it's been kind of the opposite in a
survey about social commerce the vast
majority of people said that they would
never use it about a fourth of people
said that they'd never seen it and
unfortunately three percent said that
they've used it and they will never use
it again so there's obviously a big
problem with it where people are just
resistant to the idea and also globally
it doesn't seem that people are that
interested in utilizing a social buy
button within their updates on their
fees so most companies are going to be
cutting back their social buy buttons
after this holiday season now
interestingly that doesn't mean that
even though global users are not
interested in it that definitely comes
down to regional preferences because
it's not everywhere that this is
happening specifically in Southeast Asia
thirty percent of digital sales are
social commerce and so I think it has a
lot to do with culture and has a lot to
do with the comfort level of people
utilizing mobile as a primary device
rather than a secondary device in most
Western countries the death
stop is the primary device and the
mobile was the secondary device and so
people had that option and then choose
what we're seeing more in the southeast
asia region the mobile is the primary
device so because of that culturally
people are more open to it they react to
it and they almost expect that kind of
service so we're seeing that there's
definite differences in different
regions based on different marketing
methodologies and just because it didn't
work in one part of the world does it
mean that won't work in another again
it's one of those where you have to try
and see where your audience is and where
they're most comfortable now one of the
things that was very effective for black
friday are some retailers decided really
to opt out of black friday re i was one
of those retailers were they close to
their store their physical store on
black friday and they started a twitter
hashtag called opt outside so they
closed all of their stores but in doing
so they saw as twenty-six percent
increase in their e-commerce traffic now
this year they did this was last year
that they started this this year their
app gave you ideas on things you could
do going outside so you could take a
walk do a hike ride a motorcycle all
kinds of ideas that they gave you and
then once you did it they wanted you to
take a picture of yourself hashtag it
opt outside and upload it through your
network and so really kind of going
against the trend of going to the stores
and fighting with the crowds they went
the opposite way and closing their
stores and challenging people to go
outside and do something fun rather than
go shopping
so the primary observation that we're
seeing from all of this data is that
cyber week or black friday cyber monday
thanks all that it it's really now an
entire quarter so we're calling black
friday quarter q4 that's because because
consumers they're thinking about it and
they're expecting to start shopping long
before Black Friday in fact most
shoppers are expecting holiday promote
promotions to begin by October also most
shoppers are expecting deals before
Black Friday and so when we think about
it this whole holiday season is now an
entire quarter three months of people
buying and browsing long before the
actual day comes and we're even seeing
it among retailers or there's less
emphasis on even naming the day of black
friday or cyber monday amazon only
twenty-two percent of their advertising
actually mentioned Black Friday and only
nineteen percent of its ads mentioned
cyber monday so they're looking at it as
an entire season rather than specific
days the other observation is that a lot
of the retailer's because they are
cutting all of their prices in order to
compete in this holiday season they are
losing money and not everyone is there
but some have and some have lost money
now when you look at what influences a
lot of the holiday shopping number one
is discounts this is worldwide here the
number reason why people shop is for
discounts now quality and selection come
into that but we also see free shipping
and low prices really someone has to pay
when you cut your prices when you offer
discounts that money has to come from
somewhere and so even though oh
royal holiday spending increased a lot
of the major retailers are seeing a
profit decline that's because if you
keep cutting your prices if you keep
offering discounts and free shipping and
all those types of things someone has to
pay for it and so if you discount more
than you can afford you will see your
profits decline so that's a warning of
trying to compete with a lot of other
retailers that just competing on price
alone that's why a lot of people are
shopping to get the deals but you could
also lose quite a bit of money like
selling a lot of product with too big of
a discount now a couple things very
specific to India and I thought this was
interesting in the research is that the
Independence Day sales have outgrown
dwelling in the past two years and so
you can see the numbers there for this
past year and really that dwelling was
the largest shopping holiday and now
independent state and sort of grown and
outpaced that and when you look at the
five major holidays that has accounted
for 714 crore in 2016 which is an
increase from last year so overall all
holidays aren't contributing and
increasing dramatically now also we
talked about this before with devices
when we look specifically at India and
the traffic share smartphone and tablet
is about twenty-five percent and twenty
one percent of sales very significant
and so apps alone are accounting for
about eleven percent and desktop is
still about sixty four sixty eight
percent so very similar to other areas
of the world and we're seeing that
desktop is still
going to be the primary device however
mobile is becoming more and more
prevalent as people look to it as their
primary device and then also looking to
see that the uplift because of the peak
season so in India we see the the month
of october to early November that
average sales are increasing visitors
increase and overall it's growing
significantly over the past few years so
also Pacific to India one thing I
thought was very interesting is the
staff at 30s for six thirty six percent
of buyers were browsing with a different
device before making the purchase on a
final on a different device so they were
browsing maybe on their mobile and then
completed the transaction on desktop
they were able to track that for thirty
six percent of buyers so not too far off
from really kind of the rest of the
world when it comes to the trends in the
holiday season how people are buying and
what people are doing around the world
so I hope this has been helpful and
informative to you and just kind of
understanding some of the big trends
that have happened throughout the
holiday season but also the importance
of the skills that are simply learn
offers such as search engine
optimization organic search paid search
email marketing programmatic marketing
social media all these are skills that
simply learn covers and these are the
digital marketing skills that are in
demand from retailers that are taking
place in this holiday season so Richard
are going to turn it back to you great
great Matt thank you very much boy I
learned a lot I was not aware of how the
marketing is shifting
I've always been a person who really
doesn't like black friday so I've always
avoided it that's a day I go hiking and
I'm right there with REI that's the day
I take off yeah look it's great if we're
going to do now is we're going to go
into the question and answer period so
if you have some questions on your own
career path or about the topics that
were covered in today's webinar or want
more information you know definitely put
a note in the question module there for
us and I'm going to take over the screen
while we do the question and answer
period is always lots of little poll
that they have us do we just check if
you want more information you know great
team that's out there to help you with
anything and then one of the questions
it always comes up which I'll start off
with give Matt a little give us a little
break and give a chance to have the
trick you do record all our sessions so
if you do want a copy of the recording
you can go to simply learn calm and go
under support and just let them know
send them a note and usually within 24
hours they'll send you out a copy or
link once they build the link they sent
those in it out to you so we do keep a
copy of this a copy of it singular cup
it you can get a ask them to send that
over to you questions format let me go
ahead and start one of the questions off
here looking at this now what was
probably one of your favorite
experiences you've had in the marketing
field we've helped a company or you've
helped an individual just really take
off and what was what was that and what
was that like oh wow um you know I just
love the teaching part of it you know
when I i had an agency uh where we would
do digital marketing for clients and so
my favorite part was really the hiring
someone and teaching them digital
marketing
and then seeing them become successful
and not just working with clients but
also in their own personal uh their own
personal life I like to tell people my
favorite story is I I hired an intern
and he within about six months I told
the company they need to hire him so
they hired him and then about two years
later he came to me and said I'm leaving
the company and I told him whatever you
want you tell me and I want you to stay
he said well I don't I don't really want
to work anymore uh he said I with what
you taught me I started a couple of
businesses and I'm making more money
from those businesses that I'm making
here and that is probably the proudest I
felt uh you know regardless of working
with clients working with you know big
brands is I taught someone how to become
independent start their own business and
be successful and it changed their life
so that that's probably the best
experience I've had hmm excellent I have
this one I love teaching also something
wonderful about that in the snow for
everybody that certainly enjoy the
teaching market so if we're gonna ask
you what your favorite experiences let's
go with what was the worst one the
biggest challenge you faced because you
have many years of experience we've had
to deal with a lot of different
companies but the one you feel best to
show the worst one but whatever you feel
comfortable telling us about well it's
you know any time you know that it's
part of love when you work with an
agency uh you know unfortunately you
need clients and some clients can be
fantastic other clients can be
absolutely terrible to you and you know
specifically I had one client who we
gave him all instructions as far as
here's what you're to do here's what
we'll help you
and he didn't do it and and in fact what
he did do was opposite of what we said
and then he blamed us for for things not
going right so any time you work with
clients you're gonna find that that some
just will not even though they're paying
you they probably won't listen to you
and so that's the good and the bad of
having crying quite the challenge they
hire the expert and they tell you that
they're the expert yes exactly exactly
he even told me I'm hiring you because I
failed and everything I've done so I'm
gonna tell her I wouldn't knows what
they're doing and then yeah everything I
told him to do uh wasn't good enough I
have a I have a number of questions
coming in I was like to throw those in
first but let me take this one from
Rania I hope I'm saying the name right
to apologize if I if I'm getting it
wrong given the digital marketing trends
will there be a tipping point when cells
through mobile devices will overtake the
cells from the desktop also busey
digital marketing involving and it
defying the digital marketing concepts
in the future so what do you need a
trends of the future for digital
marketing can based on mobile devices
and laptops and all the different
purchasing powers we have I think we're
going to see I think mobile and desktop
are probably going to stay around this
you know probably like a 30-percent
mobile sixty percent desktop uh I think
it's going to stay there for a few years
um I don't think you're going to lose
the desktop because it's still an
integral device so I don't see anything
changing mat unless another type of
device comes out that is kind of the
best of both worlds um at this point I
really wouldn't be surprised if there is
a new device that comes out that really
will upset the market I think we're kind
of do for that um I think one of my
analysts even said that about Apple is
that the iphone has run its course
smartphones aren't pushing the
boundaries anymore and so what's going
to happen now so I think I think we're
on the verge of maybe seeing another
device in the next three to four years
until then I see the the number staying
about the same interesting that we also
interesting with all the health devices
just when you were talking about the
different devices imagine we can just
walk into your living room and say hey
order me some new blinds for the front
window or yes okay an interest guy
didn't know will probably take four or
five more or more years to develop so
that that's an interesting thing to keep
an eye on it is now and I've got one of
those devices and I absolutely love it
however I can't order anything on it I'm
not yes I can't see now unless I'm
ordering something I need that I know
it's there but and that's one of those
things where I i think they intended
people to use it that way but people
still want to see show me four or five
with the price and the terms and i'll
decide I don't want this little box
determining what I'm buying without
telling me the price so that's that's
true and I do I slope between my phone
and my computer and when I'm buying
something I look at it five or six times
now that's really true we and that comes
down to that that's the old question of
am I seeing everything I need to see and
people don't feel that way on a mobile
device unless it's designed in order to
give people that that reassurance that
they're seeing everything in the
checkout and so with one of those I
don't know what they're calling them but
like the Alexa the Google
device you're not seeing anything and so
as humans we are very visual creatures
and so I think we need to see the
options then we need to see the check
out and so unless it's typical things
that you've ordered before I I don't see
that really changing the way we shop at
least not in the next few years no no
well I think that's a letter that's very
new to although as I look told you
before we got on here I like working
with startups and I think there's an
idea for a start-up as they can rig that
to the TV we tell Alexis to turn the TV
on and show you that's what I'm a
reporter I it yeah the interesting
that's what I'm looking at let me go
ahead we got some more questions coming
in here I got Fatima thank you for the
question all the way again apologize if
I missed the names when someone has to
choose and a career between email
marketing content marketing and SEO
which one do you think it's going to
have the biggest growth scope over the
next I'm not sure it over the next one
to three years because I know marketing
changes so quickly some but over the
next period of time if they're just
jumping in there what do you think is
going to be the big catcher if you're in
starting a career in digital marketing
well I'll tell you what you that's a
great great question because between SEO
email and content marketing if you can
write great content it will work in both
SEO and email there is you know that to
me is probably where the best skills you
can have is writing and understanding
how it works in SEO and then also how to
change it according to the medium of
email and then for content writing you
know are you are you developing this
content for a white paper or are you
developing it for an infographic or
whatever it's the ability number one
the primary ability is knowing how to
write well and communicate clearly the
secondary ability is being able to match
your content to how you you know what
you're doing so what I'm saying there is
all three of those areas are going to be
growing in the next few years and if you
just learn the basics of writing and
communicating you will be able to use
that skill in all three areas excellent
that's true that's what I've noticed in
the marketing is how to get everything
to a line and come together so it's one
set of content going to cost three
different marketing techniques or for
excellent going going back to devices
this is a great one by Natalya have you
done any analysis on wearables are these
having any impact on the digital
marketing or is this to really my thing
to really not there with what their
channel a place is going to be in the
market well you know in as soon as you
say wearables that is such a huge market
um now unfortunately some of the
analysis that I saw is that the market
for wearables themselves went down
significantly this year compared to last
year they thought wearables would be
much higher but the especially the the
watches have not taken off like they
thought they would and so they really
had to reduce their estimates and they
said they just did not see the market
jump on them like they thought they
would uh I don't think but I don't think
the watches are going to make that big
of an impact um like I said I think
something is coming in the next few
years where it's a different device just
like how ten years ago the iphone was a
completely
different device that changed how we
thought how we used uh what we could do
I think there is another device coming
out soon that I think will maybe be some
kind of wearable possibly but something
that's much more integrated rather than
just being an extension of another
device so i don't see wearables
producing much of an impact in their
current state yeah that's interesting
because i keep putting off buying a
fancy watch or data link watch one of
these days i probably will of course
when they get that when they get those
google glasses as a little pop-up window
and has facial recognition i'll be Lila
but all the pre order before it see how
my ability to recognize people in a
crowd really bad i think that that was
i'll change politics to it'll be like
the new politics is the google glass
yeah yeah knocking too yeah yeah and
that's funny because the google laughs
you know it just didn't take off and now
we're seeing some i'm trying to think
who is it is it uh i think it's
interesting or snapchat one of them has
come out with their own set of glasses
that you can do and so i wouldn't be
surprised to see something come out
that's integrated with facebook live
where you could really kind of wear it
and record your life for facebook live
um that just seems to go hand in hand
but it'll be interesting to see how that
becomes more and more i think it will
happen more socially rather than
something that's product driven yes
they wanted yeah and I imagine that it
will eventually evolved into another way
of advertising yeah down download our
free software onto your google glasses
all you have to do is look at ads that
pop up another people's shirts yeah yeah
be great yeah I'm sure that someday we
might have something like that if you
guess so I just a question we have
somebody over here is wondering if you
are hiring yes if you have an opening in
your team I don't have we don't have a
direct contact you can certainly send
through the tech support a note if you
want to send Matt a message or something
like that user they can do that you know
I don't even know what our policy is on
sharing email strictly on here but
generally that well I'll answer that
question is I i sold my agency two years
ago and so now I just do training and so
that I'm not ironing anybody I just do
training right now mmm so if they want
to have an opportunity to work with you
they need to make sure they get in your
class is what you're saying yeah
absolutely absolutely and that is one of
our instructors that's one of the things
we do with the webinars so if you you
know definitely any of our training is
simply learn you know take the time to
check out your instructor and a lot of
times you go to these webinars you get a
chance to know who they are a wonderful
way to find out more what are you doing
about you don't have a training team we
have different kind of trainings for
teachers here at simply learn usually
they want somebody who already has a
certain amount of years of experience
and then you come on board so if you
have some digital marketing experience
you've had a little chance on that
definitely sent a note to simply learn
if you that's something you're
interested in doing you send that over
to the support email let them know so we
have another question from Natalia and
left to go back to channels how do you
see smart houses we were just talking
about Alexis playing a role in down
homers in the near future
I can just see walking into the living
room and saying hey Alexis I need to buy
a jacket what do I just saw one where
they're a startup that was I wasn't
working with them but I went to their
preview their stuff and they're taking a
digital picture of what you want so you
would take a picture of like a brown
couch or something similar then you
extend the picture in and instead of it
you know sort of typing in brown couch
and get all these weird things it
analyzes the picture and finds that
information for you oh yeah I think that
would be a cool thing in a smart house
where you would see ya ecommerce is
you'd be able to have some kind of
camera interface I said I didn't mean to
take over the answer on that I'm sorry
Matt no that's what the I think that's
what the Amazon fold was a couple years
ago um it would do things like that now
the Consumer Electronics Show earlier in
this month mm-hmm everything was the
connected house and so as I put my so
here were some of the products at the
Consumer Electronics Show as I put my
food into my refrigerator my
refrigerator would in the bar code of
all the food and it would keep an
inventory as well as the date that it
was placed in the refrigerator the
refrigerator's also had TV screens on
them that would give me suggestions as
to what I could make based on what was
in the refrigerator and if I chose one
of those suggestions the recipe would
show on the TV screen and it would then
automatically preheat the smart oven
that is located in your kitchen and so
that would start going so that's sort of
an the idea of a lot of this what's
going on is that all your appliances
would be talking to each other um and
everything ultimately being voice
controlled so likes TV everything now
that
lays into commerce at this point I'm not
really sure is is it going to change the
way people purchase is it going to
change the way that people are shopping
at this point a lot of these smart
devices are very high ticket items be
smart refrigerator that I talked about
was about I think it was probably twelve
thousand dollars um and and it goes up
to 25,000 for an appliance that is an
amazing amount of money and so while
they are coming up with the technology
by attaching it to a large kitchen
appliances it's going to have a very
very slow adoption and until it gets to
the point where the average person can
afford it or even once it because I you
know if I have a choice between a
regular refrigerator and a regular
refrigerator that's a smart refrigerator
and the price tag is still thousands of
a dollars difference I don't see the
advantage yet so part of the whole
connected home smart home is the price
tag associated with it it's just not in
most people's budgets to spend two to
three times more on something just to
have it connected when we get there when
the prices are in line with other types
of products so I'm not spending two to
three times or more or something just
because it'll connect that's when I
think we'll start seeing um more i would
say custom applications or those types
of things being developed for that on
the other side we still have the issue
of security and i'm one of those that
i'm on the outside of the connected home
them because I'm just not sure the
security of it is there yet where I
would trust it and I think that's going
to be a major problem moving forward
over the next few years hmm excellent
yeah I would be afraid of it turning
itself on when I didn't want to have me
I might have known as hell in 2010 and
another kind of dates me an older movie
we have a thanks from a be checked for
earlier just a quick reminder if you
want a copy of the presentation you do
need to go to ww simply learn com you
can scroll to the bottom and then just
send a note to support and say hey I was
at the holiday marketing review and wrap
up with Matt Bailey can I get a copy of
this and they'll you nail it over to you
but if you have to go there and send
them a note also if we missed any
questions don't forget if you go to
community simply learn calm under the
community go into the digital marketing
and post questions in there and we do
have experts you go in there and review
those it's an open forum for those who
are students we have an additional
forums close what we do keep an open
forum for questions so if we missed
something definitely go in there and ask
that question if it comes to mind let's
see thanks for the answer from aranya
pratik you're welcome you're welcome
glad to have you guys here if you think
we have time for like one more question
Matt before we wrap it up I as if you
were new and you're really just starting
into the industry what would be the what
would you suggest would be the best set
of certifications or coursework or
direction to go in or what to look at so
you can even figure out what directions
to go in I know a lot of it depends on
what you enjoy what's good at two Wow
yeah if toughest one for last I know you
know it I find that get as much of an
overview worse to start
see anything its involved so in the in
digital marketing I think they have the
digital marketing certificate and it
covers a strategy cover social media
covers I think youtube so I would look
for an overview that covers as many
subjects as possible and learn a little
bit about each one and then from there
figure out what interests you what i
have found in hiring dozens of people
for this industry is it's a matter of
personality and what you enjoy and so i
would try to expose people to all
different kinds of digital marketing and
usually they would be drawn to one or
two of the digital marketing channels or
disciplines and then they would pursue
it and so that is that that's the great
part of digital marketing is there's so
many directions you can go in and even
if you learn something it's easy to
transfer those skills to another skill
set as well so learn about everything
that's there pick and choose one or two
pursue it and then you'll be amazed to
how much it crosses over into the next
skill set as well excellent excellent
that that's all that's good advice for
anything is find a mountain climate and
then when you get to the I find another
mountain okay come I like that you see
it's been popular at least on my social
Channel I saw once i saw it 30 times but
i still like it you guys I like that
I we still have a couple more minutes if
anybody has any last questions before we
wrap up I did go ahead and close the
poll that we can see the holiday
marketing last slide there if we don't
have any last minute questions i'll
probably go ahead and close the session
we do look forward if you have any
questions on the simply learn and you
visit www simply learn com you can
certainly they'll have a pop-up window
and you can chat with the person there
and then get you in the right direction
and you can view the courses that simply
learn at offers you can also go into the
community they could post PS something
you're interested in you can look in
there and see whether people are saying
or post your question in there it's a
great place to get some more information
the public forums are always a wonderful
place to start and then you know from
there if you continue on definitely ask
for Matt you know you can say hey I'd
like to work with this instructor on
this class and see what he's teaching it
Morgan go check out some the other
instructors we have a lot of great
instructors I actually have a lot of fun
working with all of them that's what
you've done it all mad cuz you've been
quite enjoyable today oh thank you thank
you and whether you know you just flew
across the ocean or having a little
trouble with the voice there and still a
great presentations I appreciate that
and appreciate you making the time to be
here tonight for us it's nice for some
of you it's early morning absolutely
yeah let's go ahead and then thank
everybody for being here I look forward
to seeing you guys in our classrooms
what's that we'll go ahead and close the
session and I wish everybody a good day
or good evening everybody take care and
goodbye for now